and Clark formatory Chancellor and it
seems we have the picture good to see
you and I was just asking law Clark what
you make of the mess uh the mess we
appear to be in
well well I have my feelings of what
everybody would expect to be I must be
that I've never known a budget uh course
a financial crisis immediately like this
I when I listened to the budget I was
rather astounded by its contents and uh
I hope we very rapidly get out of it I I
was uh hoping that now we've gone
through the circus of the leadership
election we were now going to get down
to dealing with a serious National
crisis and I was quite prepared to give
them time and wish them success in the
national interests but they have made a
catastrophic start the the the the the
the budget was a serious mistake and it
has caused a serious problem right so
the government is blaming International
factors I mean you believe this is quite
clearly a self-inflicted crisis
well it's an additional crisis of course
they're right that they've taken over at
a time when they have a lot of very
serious problems to deal with and
economically they have a very unusual
combination Britain is entering into a
recession we're in a recession now but
this recession is being combined with
high inflation inflation properties
doesn't occur in recessions inflations
more often when you're in some sort of
inflationary boom that has to be quiet
and down but they've got an inflationary
recession and their budget was put
forward in the Apparently naive belief
that firstly they had to deliver tax
cards so that would give them a good
headline the next day and that if you
gave tax cuts to the very rich that you
would attack really good Bankers to
London that would get us back to growth
and it would trickle down to everybody
else well I hope that's all been torn up
and that they're now sitting down
listening to the treasury the bank of
England and those serious economic
economies so I'm sure happy to give them
proper advice but we've just been
hearing from the treasury Minister
saying these are the right plans because
they might they make our economy more
competitive we will get on and deliver
these plans
I didn't know that I I was not sharing
the criticism of their silence at the
moment because I very much hope that
they were sitting down carefully and
taking proper advice and considering
very carefully what they were going to
say before they came out and responded
and
um that that's uh I I I I think that is
a great pity what we needed was a clear
statement that they would stick to
fiscal discipline that of course the
problems of inflation were caused by
President Putin and also by other real
problems in Supply problems and Food
Supplies throughout the world they
couldn't cure it straight away but they
were going to combine in a sensible
prudent way getting down inflation with
bringing to an end the recession
lessening the recession getting us back
to growth they'll be re-elected in two
years time if they're judged by then to
be competent people will forgive them
some mistake so this isn't quite black
Wednesday I don't think but they they've
now got to demonstrate that their
responsibility is heading out on the
right course and actually you know where
they need to be in two years time the
election is able to say to people look
we were right it worked out all right in
the end we're now beginning to get a bit
of growth we've got low inflation we're
back on course to become a good modern
economy again because the British
economy has a lot of underlying
strengths we're not um uh third world
country or some country that's usually
in this sort of problem like Argentina
or Greece so it begs the question then
why do you think they proceeded in the
way they did we had Rishi sunak after
all warning that what would happen to
the pound what would happen to on the
guilt markets what would happen to
interest rates
I voted for Rishi suda yes no I think I
think they've got too much political
excitement and hype and hubris uh after
all the rather over frantic over long
debate in the leadership election and
they were planned straight away to give
effect to all the things they've been
actually warned about by Rishi and many
others uh and they were mainly heading
for the good headlines that they got in
the Daily Mail and the Daily Express The
Daily Express give me glowing headline
at last a real conservative budget well
I don't think any previous conservative
government at least of all Margaret
Thatcher is the most successful we've
had since the war would have done
anything like this although they did
make a slight slip under the Thatcher
government deal with it in in 1988. well
that's the point I mean this is your
party this is the party that was known
uh for economic responsibility or that's
what they said they should be known for
yes which is why black Wednesdays did
such terrible uh harm to us uh then
quite lasting harm for quite a long time
um but uh we did get the economy back
after black Wednesday uh Blair only got
elected because by saying he was going
to follow my Economic Policy which he
did for a couple of years uh stick to my
figures if you recall because the
economy was the only thing we were in
the lead and the polls on in 1997 but we
just torn ourselves apart and we
continued to do so with a stupid
argument over Europe uh but that that we
were quite unelectable but but the the
reason conceptual party has been the
governing party for the majority of my
lifetime has been because it's always
been regarded as safe with the money
good on the economy much more reliable
than the feckless labor party right just
finally what about the position of the
chancellor now I mean does it
all add up to a resigning matter
no I don't but I like crazy quartering
and we can't keep having a different
chance or every other week uh he's a
good intelligent guy uh he's just got
the stand up to Rishi or stand up to the
prime minister or the prime minister's
advisors if they're the source of the
problem he's got to make a really
serious statement that he is going to
stick to fiscal discipline that we are
is going to be a long difficult course
with a difficult winter but uh and and
he he has got to make a reassuring
statement and the bank mustn't get left
behind the curve again well they're
going to have to raise interest rates
they should have raised interest rates
yesterday in my opinion not by some
Panic threaten large huge sum but
another half percent just to show there
are independent and doing their proper
job and both of them need to come out
with serious solid statements the
government and the bank and not just say
the letters are know in November we need
a restatement of policy and then
personally I like crazy I wish him well
he's a highly intelligent guy just
learned from this settle down get some
calm back and start pursuing a more
serious and responsible policy okay Lord
Clark appreciate you coming on the
program thanks very much indeed
pleasure